what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we cover
the most powerful characters in comics
and today we're discussing one of the dc
universe's strongest characters orion of
the new gods so orion was created by
jack kirby and first appeared in new
gods number one in 1971 and orion's the
son of darkseid the ruler of apocalypse
which had been at war with new genesis
which is ruled by highfather practically
forever now in an attempt to bring an
end to the fighting darkseid and high
father brokered a deal where they would
exchange sons now darkseid sent orion to
live on new genesis while high fathers
sent his son miracle man to live on
apocalypse now the other part of this is
that orion was also the subject of a
prophecy that foretold that he would
actually defeat his father darkseid in a
battle for apocalypse and so as he grew
up on new genesis orion was constantly
struggling between the peaceful
upbringing he was receiving and his
short temper and violent nature so he
needed a mother box a piece of
technology used by many of the new gods
to keep his temper in line but even then
keeping his temper in check is a
constant challenge for orion even so
despite his lineage as the son of
darkseid orion developed a fierce
loyalty to new genesis and grew to
become one of its strongest and most
devoted defenders as well as an
occasional member of the justice league
now orion possesses various superpowers
due to his new god physiology including
superhuman strength durability speed and
stamina all of which are on a level
comparable with superman wonder woman
and darkseid now orion was strong enough
to shatter mountains with his punches
and to pick up a mountain and throw it
he was also able to restrain superman
which is no small feat and his punches
were powerful enough to harm captain
adam one of the most powerful characters
in the dc universe and on top of all
that he's able to lift more than 100
tons but he was also able to stun high
father and on one occasion knocked
darkseid down and on another was even
able to rip darkseid's heart out and so
in terms of speed orion is able to
travel the distance between earth and
new genesis in less than a heartbeat and
was able to keep up with black racer
who's basically the grim reaper for the
new gods and orion's durability is also
insane not only does he take punches
from superman without being faced but he
took a blast from a weapon known as the
void hound which had basically destroyed
10 solar systems and he did that without
being harmed at all and on another
occasion he was able to walk through a
nuclear reactor that produced as much
energy as a thousand nuclear explosions
per minute so orion's basically
invulnerable now in the event that he is
harmed orion possesses a regenerative
healing factor that can negate any
damage he sustains now in addition to
his superhuman physical attributes orion
is a skilled combatant and a highly
trained warrior i mean he's one of the
absolute best in fact when he was
undercover on apocalypse those in charge
of training soldiers remarked that orion
is the best they've ever trained and
that's saying a lot given that
apocalypse is known for producing some
absolutely brutal fighters the furies
are a perfect example of that but this
fighting prowess combined with the
superhuman abilities make orion capable
of taking down entire armies of
super-powered beings which he's done on
multiple occasions including being able
to take on an entire army of new gods
which are some of the most powerful
beings in all of dc comics now in
addition to all of this orion also has
access to a vast cosmic source of energy
known as the astro force now the astral
force is derived from the source itself
a seemingly endless source of energy
that exists beyond the border of the dc
universe that basically gave rise to all
life within the universe but the astral
force is basically the antithesis to the
omega force that's frequently wielded by
dark side and was bestowed upon orion by
highfather now his control of the astral
force grants orion a variety of powers
including energy manipulation which he
uses in a wide variety of ways on one
occasion orion harnessed the omega force
into a shield that stood up to an attack
from darkseid's omega force while he was
being amped by the anti-life equation
now when he uses this ability to produce
energy blasts they have been strong
enough to blast superman to the other
side of the planet take down characters
as powerful as firestorm and starfire in
one shot and even incapacitate starro a
villain so powerful that he prompted the
justice league to come together for the
first time to defeat him so orion has
also been able to blast planets out of
their orbit and produce enough energy to
repair holes in the fabric of reality
now orion can also use the astral force
to manipulate matter like repairing his
astral bands and astro harness equipment
that he uses to help him harness the
astro force itself and he's also
displayed some reality warping abilities
as well as he undid some reality warping
that had been caused by the source but
on one occasion orion's power even
surpasses what he's capable of when
wielding the astral force when he taps
into the source of the beast now this
occurred when orion pursued darkseid
into the source and merges with all of
creation when accessing this level of
power orion is able to easily defeat
darkseid and restrain high father so in
this form he's even further beyond omega
level and this is a level of power that
he seems to be able to access whenever
he allows his rage to overpower his
restraint so while this technically is
an amped up form of orion it seems to be
one that is fairly accessible should he
ever choose to use it but yeah that's
basically what makes orion so powerful i
bet you guys had no idea this guy was
that op orion's broken man like orion is
just a really really broken character in
dc comics but with that being said guys
should dc comics do more with orion
that's the question i want to ask you
guys does dc need to do more with the
character of orion let me know down in
the comment section let me know who else
you guys want to see thank you all for
watching and i will catch you guys later
peace